how was your summer would you have a
good summer do you get could you get
time off in the summer don't you yeah
with this this summer we did we had a
little bit of time off it was great we
we actually which is rare for us we like
took a big vacation with the kids we
brought them to Europe which is a
continent on the other side of the
Atlantic Ocean you condescending bastard
yeah yeah we brought them over there and
it was really fun but we decided we're
gonna do it like right we're gonna take
the kids around to different cities and
have a guide in each city and each
museum will have a guide and really like
go through and and and learn about
everything ourselves but also see our
children learning about Europe and
history and art and and almost
immediately the the kids they're eight
and ten they just stopped giving a [ __ ]
yes right away of course their agent
says oh boy should have called me I
could have told you yeah I know like
what is wrong with us yeah so we were
like we were we ended up in Venice after
a couple of weeks and by the time like
two weeks in we're in Venice looking at
statues and
art and stuff and they were so so bored
and we were like it the Statue of
Poseidon there and my son is just kind
of so bummed and he just grabs him he's
like daddy look the penis hair and and I
was like yeah yeah those is pretty
awesome penis here like I was I could
feel the board I was also born where
absolutely get you were getting excited
too at this new low that you having
yes we're checking out Poseidon's pubes
and it was its high point
you took a photo and I think you trade
it online did you know that I think you
did and this was you yeah
that's a good dad making sure you get
that out on social media that's right
you know so funny when I took my kids
through we took them to Paris yeah and
my son at the time to be fair he was
like six but he had an epic meltdown in
front of every single great landmark and
I started taking little sneaky snaps of
him because he'd be in would be in the
front of the pyramid of the Louvre and
hit be on the ground just like that and
then Eiffel Tower and no pitching a bit
and I thought I want to make this into a
calendar melting down in front of every
great land Mike the cow and I did not I
thought that would be too cruel and I
didn't couldn't figure out a way to
monetize it that's amazing
we actually we took the kids on a
hot-air balloon ride in Tuscany I mean
so beautiful your Tuscany and you're up
a mile up in the air and it's just
gorgeous
and I swear three minutes in both the
kids asked if we they could look at our
phones and then they sat on the bottom
of the basket just I love that if they
just stand over the basket they can see
all of us I know in the air and they're
at the bottom and they're probably
looking at balloon shot you have to
working on their phone
Porsche or
you